why the hell does the Dragon Ball Manga
call this guy vegerot or better yet
where does the ey in Vegito even come
from his correct name as can be found in
the subs for the anime is Vegito with an
E why well v g is from Vegeta and tto is
from kakaroto which is how Goku's Sayan
name kakarat is said in Japanese so then
the manga came along and said wait a
minute in America we don't call him
kakarat we call him kakarat and then
went with
vegerot now this isn't wrong per se but
it is so wrong it feels like I need to
take a bath after just saying it then
lastly we have FUNimation take on the
character name where they decided to
keep the Vegito name but changed the
spelling and threw in an I from your
guess is as good as mine I want answers
FUNimation gen fukunaga get on the phone
answer my calls and explain where you
got the eye from